Hey youtubers it's Charlie, only two more
episodes of Game of Thrones this season. So
because we spend so much time during the hiatus
theorycrafting I wanted to do a bonus video
for my favorite prophecies. I'm only including
things that are put forth as prophecy, so
like if Tyrion suffered a wine induced nightmare
that he was forcibly married to The Mountain
as punishment for losing trial by combat,
it's not a real prophecy. There's over fifty
that I know of, but this will just be my TOP
5. So if you guys want I can always do a follow
up with a longer breakdown later this summer.
Don't forget that the next round of the weekly
giveaway starts when I post my Episode 9 review
tonight. I pick a random subscriber from the
comments on that video. It's not a contest
or anything. It's just a way for me to say
thank you to you guys for being so awesome.
For all the prophecies I'm including the character
that it's given to and when they learned it
in the books if anyone wants to read the whole
thing. Here we go Number 5 - Maggy The Frog
So Cersei casually mentions her name on the
show out of context. In the books Maggy was
a fortune teller in Lannisport that Cersei
visited when she was 10 with 2 of her childhood
friends during a tournament for King Aerys.
Maggy let Cersei ask 3 questions but gave
her four answers. She predicted who Cersei
would marry, Robert not Rhaegar who had actually
just been knighted, Rhaegar that is. He was
about 7 years older than Cersei.
Maggy also predicted Cersei would be Queen,
but that a younger more beautiful queen would
come and cast down and take all she held dear.
The theories behind this are that the younger
queen is either Maergary or Daenerys. In the
books Maergary isn't supposed to be more beautiful
than Cersei but because of the Purple Wedding
and Cersei's suggestion that she marry Tommen
it's still a pretty even guess as to who the
younger more beautiful queen is.
Maggy then predicted the total number of living
children she and Robert would have, separately.
She predicted the total number of Robert's
bastards. Remember there were a lot, and Gendry
is still floating somewhere south of Dragonstone.
And the total number of Cersei's living children,
3. Remember she had a stillborn child with
Robert. Maggy didn't say she would lose a
child but she predicted the total number and
Her 3 plus Robert's bastards hit the number.
I won't say what the total number of Robert's
bastards is just in case the show changes
something.
There was one more big part that relates to
the Valonqar which is High Valyrian for little
brother. But I'm not going to include it in
this video just because I think it's kind
of spoilery.
If you want to read the whole prophecy it's
in Feast for Crows pages 540 to 541.
Number 4 - The Winged Snake
This is one of Bran's visions at the end of
book 2. In it his eyes are clouded with smoke
and ash and he sees a winged snake breathing
a river of flame in the sky. Behind the cliffs
tall fires were eating the stars.
Because of the timing most people interpret
the smoke and ash to be the burning of Winterfell.
Like we see it burning in the opening credits
every week. As for the dragon, there's a couple
theories. The craziest is that there's a dragon
underneath Winterfell that has just laid dormant
forever and the destruction of winterfell
woke it. There are hot springs beneath winterfell,
so it's possible but not probable.
The other theory is that the dragon is supporting
evidence of Jon Snow being a Targaryen. He's
the dragon rising from Winterfell.
It's open to interpretation, but as a tangent,
Jojen claims that visions can be wrong but
greensight is not. And Bran and Jojen both
have the power of greensight. Which implies
that all of Bran's visions are much closer
to the truth than other characters.
Of course Jojen could also be misinterpreting
the claim about greensight too.
You can read this one in Book 2 page 699
Number 3 - Azor Ahai
This prophecy comes from Melisandre and is
always mentioned in the same sentence with
the sword Lightbringer. But Azor and Lightbringer
are actually two separate prophecies.
The Azor prophecy says that when the Red Star
Bleeds and Darkness Gathers Azor Ahai shall
be born again amidst Smoke and Salt. Azor
Ahai is the mythical champion of the Red God,
Melisandre believes that he or she will lead
the army of the Red God against the Great
Other and his host of white walkers.
The Red Star is the comet, which the show
has done already but it was more of a visual.
Characters don't talk a lot about astronomy.
The Darkness Gathering is a reference to the
coming battle with the Great Other. Like the
Long Night, the last great battle with the
white walkers. I'll have a link to that video
at the end of this if you want to learn more
about it.
I mentioned that Melisandre tells Stannis
he is Azor Ahai because they are on Dragonstone,
the place of Smoke and Salt. But alternatively,
that person could be Daenerys who was literally
born as a child at Dragonstone.
For anyone that's not a book reader, Dragonstone
is the Westerosi based ancestral home of the
Targaryens. Their true ancestral home was
the Valyrian Freehold but you get the idea.
The important thing to remember about Azor
Ahai is that the person has to be RE-Born.
So if you want to think Daenerys is Azor Ahai,
you have to look at that scene from season
1 where she stepped into Drogo's funeral pyre
and emerged with the dragons. That was when
the comet first appeared, she wept salt tears,
you get the smoke from Drogo's flames and
she was reborn as the mother of dragons.
It doesn't mean she's Azor Ahai, but I think
it's a very strong case if you ever wanted
to argue it with your friends.
If you want to read the passage it's in Book
3 page 289.
Number 2 - Daughter of Death
This is another Daenerys prophecy that's super
long so I'm going to condense. The title of
the prophecy comes from a passage that reads
"mother of dragons, daughter of death..."
She has visions that represent the deaths
of all those close to her including her brother
Rhaegar and what his dying words were. Robert
killed him at the Ruby Ford in the Trident.
We don't actually know what his last words
were, but the prophecy says that he whispered
a woman's name. The best theory being Lyanna
Stark's name. If Robert heard him say it,
it's not something he would have ever told
anyone. Since he was in love with Lyanna himself.
Daenerys then has a vision of Lightbringer,
the mythical flaming sword of Azor Ahai but
it was being held by a blue eyed king that
cast no shadow. Yes it sounds a lot like the
white walker we saw at the end of episode
4. But the stronger theory I think is that
it represented the shadow baby that killed
Renly, since that was happening around the
same time Daenerys had these visions.
It also suggests that Daenerys and Stannis
might meet for better or worse at some point.
There's a lot of potential spoilery parts
to her visions that relate to the Mummer's
Dragon and the Stone Dragon so I'm going to
skip over those parts. Please if you're a
book reader use the spoiler tag if you want
to talk about it in the comments.
But the rest of her visions are a mixture
of things that might have happened had her
child Rhaego lived and things that we've seen
happen. Like the liberation of her army in
Yunkai.
The whole prophecy is a collection of like
17 different passages that deal with stuff
from Book 1 to potentially the end of the
series. Visions could always be things that
we haven't seen in the books yet. So if you
do want to read the whole thing be careful
for potential spoilers. But it's in Book 2
pages 515 to 516, my final one is also part
of this House of the Undying epic montage.
and my Number 1 favorite Prophecy - The Dragon
Has 3 Heads
A lot of people refer to this as the 3 heads
of the Dragon as if they're three different
characters.
One of the rooms Daenerys sees in her visions
is of Rhaegar and Elia of Dorne with a newborn
baby Aegon. The one the Mountain is supposed
to have killed. She learns that Rhaegar believed
that his children were the fulfilment of the
Azor Ahai prophecy, and in Daenerys vision
Elia asks Rheagar to play a song and he says
this is the "prince who was promised", "and
his is a song of ice and fire."
he turned, looked at Daenerys and said, "there
must be one more." "The Dragon has three heads".
Rhaegar was naming his children after Aegon
the conqueror, Elia was pregnant with Rhaenys
when she was killed by the mountain. Implying
that Rhaegar intended to have one more baby
girl at a future date.
So the 3 heads of the Dragon is really just
one piece of the fulfilment of the Azor Ahai
prophecy.
But that doesn't mean Rhaegar's dead children
were the 3 heads of the dragon. George RR
Martin has said that the three heads of the
Dragon need not all be Targaryens.
But a lot of people, myself included, think
that Martin is just speaking cleverly without
lying. Meaning that there are characters alive
on the show that belong to other houses that
don't know they're Targaryens.
If anything is clear on Game of Thrones, it's
that even highborn people sleep around.
Jon Snow is the most famous theorized Targaryen,
but I don't want to name the other one just
because I haven't seen any of you guys comment
on them so I don't want to spoil the surprise
if it comes true.
But if you do want to comment on who you think
the three heads of the dragon are. Just use
the spoiler tag. In my opinion, it's one of
the most popular things to theorycraft in
the fandom.
So I'll be posting my episode 9 video after
it airs tonight. I'm usually pretty good about
getting it up by 10 PM Pacific Time. Youtube
has been kind of buggy lately, so if you're
worried you won't see it you can either follow
me on social or just sign up for alerts in
your subscription tab.
Right now click here for that episode 9 video.
I'll add the annotation as soon as I post
it. And click here for Monday's Q&A video.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!